we've actually made titty tassels before
[Music]
and I'm super excited for many reasons
not least of which is to be done with
wedding planning wedding planning is not
for the faint of heart there are so many
details your emotions are all wrapped up
in it and everything is so god damn
expensive I started to think maybe I
should have DIY had a lot more so I
searched on Pinterest for the easiest
wedding decorations you could make I
found a bunch and then I realized I do
not have the emotional bandwidth at this
time to even begin to start a DIY
project so I'm making my co-workers and
friends try it
I got a married couple I got an engaged
couple well let's see what they can do
we are planning a wedding and it is
horrifying we got married last year we
had our one-year anniversary of this
summer yeah we did it's a lie yeah
there's so much to do there's so many
tiny details we have both South Asian
and African family it was three days as
well I have a ton of DIY stuff pinned
yeah but I also know myself and I know
I'm not that good at making things there
were these just like huge like 3d
flowers that I wanted to make even if
they're a practice round of making them
but it totally was a disaster I think
I'll be better than Sarah he's probably
right
it looks like it's tassels that hang
like this from a string at once or one
person I didn't mean to I mean two at
once like yeah I'm not too late
hold a piece of tissue paper in half and
in half the other way cut strips toward
the fold to create fringe leaving about
one inch uncut at the fold line already
clean partway through my first piece of
tissue paper and I'm already over it
like these are for our wedding can you
please take this seriously
why are way thicker than yours like mine
are fit good cuts anybody what's the
what is fringe mean I don't know what
that means funny like like blunt rolling
technique like with tassels on the end
of it no but I feel like it's just like
tie it
that'll have to be I think it would take
at least eight hours to make there's no
way weddings worth of these tassels but
it doesn't look fantastic we're about to
do like DIY flower centerpieces out of
paper
and I'm actually interested in this guy
new flowers would be expensive but I
didn't realize how expensive I've heard
of people making fabric flowers I'm
considering it and we want to make the
petal a bunch of petals and then we tie
them together so let's just make some
starting look like a flower how do you
change directions just like you know
just like flow just to show you what
Sarah just did she used the instructions
portion of the team I'm so stressed up
they were like this and then the next
picture is like a beautiful flower I
don't know how it got there go for it go
for it I'm like gonna go on Pinterest
and unpin everything I ever pinned hope
you're getting service muttering under
her breath while she makes flowers we
are not done I refuse to make oh that's
way too much work real flowers it's
still plant base material we are now
going to make marble votive this is the
votive you put a candle in it you just
like drop that drop little roll done put
a few drops of nail polish in the water
probably going too fast
there's gently different little surface
oh man you spend so much more time on it
your looks April you should I take a
lesson learned on this one is don't do
it
some of this DIY stuff it's like I get
that you need to have decorations at
your wedding but like you know you can
chill out a little bit
it's like communal joy and also communal
suffering like anybody died the ili you
do you have any faith in me to DIY
anything at our wedding maybe like an
outfit for our dog but if you're into it
like definitely do it because it'll make
your wedding like really unique and
personalized none of this matters it's
just a wedding
what misgiving like what is a baby but
like the world's most important DIY
project that's a stretch
[Music]